네, 안녕하세요. 요즘에 상권이
굉장히 [음악] 좀 많이 어렵다라고
하는데 그 와중에 살아남는 상권들이
있습니다. [음악] 그런 상권들의
공통점이 하나 있는데 바로 외국인들이
많이 오는 곳입니다. 그래서 제가
오늘 주제는 외국인이 오는 상권만
살아남는다라는 [음악] 주제로 촬영을
해 보도록 하겠습니다. 어, 우선
외국인 관광객이 굉장히 많이
늘어났어요. 2019년도가 제일
피크였는데 그때 한 1700만 명
정도 방문을 했습니다. [음악]
그러다가 이제 코로나가 있고 난 뒤에
관광객이 확 줄었다가 최근에 좀 많이
[음악] 회복되면서 2024년도에 어
거의 1700만 명까지 회복되는
[음악]
수준으로 관광객이 많이 몰리기
시작했는데 그 관광객 중에서도
중국인이나 일본인 비율이 제일
많아요. 그래서 거의 한 절반 정도
수준으로 중국인이나 일본인들이
[음악] 좀 많이 찾아오고 있고
그다음에 대만이나 미국 사람 비중도
굉장히 좀 높습니다. 네. 그래서
되게 다양한 나라의 외국인들이 많이
방문하고 있고 요즘에 뭐 K풍이 되게
좋잖아요. 그래서 뭐 K 컨텐츠라든지
뭐 넷플릭스 보고 진짜 한국의 정서를
보기 위해서 아니면 드라마에서 봤던
그런 장소를 가기 위해서 외국인들이
굉장히 좀 [음악] 많이 방문을 하고
있습니다. 그리고 지금 방문뿐만
아니라 외국인들이 소비를 굉장히 많이
하고 있어요. 그래서 거의 한
2024년도에 외국인 지출이 167억
달러입니다. 그래서 하나로 치면은 약
한 24조 정도 어 소비를 했는데
그만큼 [음악] 외국인들이 소비를 좀
많이 하고 있어요. 그래서 그러다
보니까 상권에 굉장히 큰 영향을
끼치고 있습니다. 그래서 한국 전체
외국인 관광객 수요가 [음악] 약
1,700만 명 정도 되고 그리고
일본 전체가 한 3,700만 명 정도
됩니다. 그래서 거의 한 두 배가
넘죠. 도쿄만 하더라도 관광객이 한
1400만 명 정도 돼요. 그래서
도쿄 하나 도시가 우리나라 전체
관광객 정도 될만큼 일본은 외국인
관광객 수요가 되게 많아요. 그래서
저는 어떻게 생각하냐면 지금 일본
같은 경우에는 이미 초고령화 사회에
접어들었고 국내에 이렇게 소비 가능인
거는 굉장히 좀 줄은 상태인데 어떻게
보면 외국인 때문에 지금 상권이
유지되고 있는 거거든요. 근데
우리나라 같은 경우에도 지금 이제
초고령어 사에 접어들었고 앞으로 더
[음악] 가속화될 거기 때문에 외국인
관광객 수가 굉장히 상권에 중요한
영향을 끼칠 거라고 저는 생각을
합니다. 외국인들이 지금 환율이 좋기
때문에 객단가가 [음악] 높아도
소비를 합니다. 우리가 예전에 일본이
애나가 떨어졌을 때도 되게 자주
갔잖아요. 그래서 그거와 비슷하게
지금 환율이 높기 때문에 외국인들이
되게 비싼 것도 막 소비를 해요.
예를 들어서 뭐 피부가나 막
성형학과에도 그 며칠 있는데 막 몇
천만 원을 쓰기도 하고 그 정도로
외국인들이
많은 [음악] 것뿐만 아니라 소비도
굉장히 좀 많이 하고 있다. 어
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 우리 외국인들이 많이 오는
군데가 이제 뭐 명동이라든지 [음악]
뭐 이태원도 많이 가고 그다음
한남동이라든지 그다음에 이제 강남일대
그리고 이제 뭐 성수동 이쪽을
[음악] 좀 많이 가는데 그쪽은
아무래도 외국인이 와서 소비하기가
되게 좋은 상권들이거든요. 메뉴판들
다 영어로 돼 있고 그리고 외국인들이
워낙 많이 오다 보니까 그거와 좀
[음악] 특화돼서 상권이 좀 발달돼
있거든요. 그런 것도 되게 중요한
요소인 거 같습니다. 네. 그래서
지금 요즘에 무너지는 상권들을
조심스럽게 좀 얘기하자면 내국인에
의존하고 있습니다. 그리고 이제
회식에 의존하고 있고 [음악] 근데
사실 요즘에 회식을 잘 안 해요.
우리 같은 경우에도 작년에 회식한
적이 없습니다. 진짜 손꼽을 정도로
회식이 없어지는 문화고 그게 이제
코로나 때 많이 바뀐 거 같아요.
기업 문화들도 좀 바뀌고 회식에만
의존하고 국내 사람들에 의존하는
상권들이 좀 많이 망가지기 [음악]
시작했고 외국인들이 뭔가 좋아할 만한
그런 포인트들이 있어야 되는데 코비를
하고 뭔가 경험을 하고 그다음에
쇼핑하기 좋고 뭔가 이런게 안
[음악] 돼 있는 상권들이 있거든요.
국내 시장으로만 좀 돌아가는 상권들이
많이 죽어가기 시작했습니다. 그래서
요즘에 제일 위험한 상권은 이런
특별한 스토리가 없고 그리고 이제
뻔한 상권들 있잖아요. 그런 상권들이
좀 많이 [음악]
힘든 상황인 거 같습니다. 저는
앞으로 더 심해질 거 같아요. 그래서
외국인들이 상권에 되게 중요한
포인트가 될 거고 그리고 우리나라
자체가 지금 이런 소비 가능 인구가
계속 줄어들고 있는 상태고 그러다
보니까 국내 그 사람으로만 상권을
유지하기 쉽지 [음악] 않은 시장이
더 심해질 것 같습니다. 저는
고객들한테도 최근에도 그러고 매일
만날 [음악] 때마다 외국인들이 오는
상권에만 좀 투자를 하라고 하거든요.
앞으로 여러분들도 이렇게 상권에
관련된 부동산 빌딩뿐만 아니라 뭐
상가가 됐든 뭐가 됐든간에 외국인들이
오는 상권을 [음악] 좀 유심히 보실
필요가 있는 거 같아요. 최근에 제가
그 부산 갔을 때도 거기 해운돼 있는
[음악] 약국을 갔어요. 외국인들이
북적북적 하는 거예요. 그래서 그
약사님한테 어이 외국인들 진짜
많네요. 하니까 진짜 외국인 때문에
약국 유지할 수 있다라고 할 정도로
외국인의 의존도가 점점 더 높아지는
거 같습니다. 그리고 제가 앞으로
외국인들이 오는 상권을 좀 중점적으로
찍을 예정이거든요. 그래서 예를
들면은 그 다음 편에 찍을게 북총
그러니까 이제 안국역 위에 한옥마을을
[음악]
찍을 예정이에요. 그래서 거기 실제로
여러분들이 한번가 보세요. 네. 가서
보시면은 그 좁은 도로에 외국인들이
[음악]
진짜 많습니다. 그래서 여기가 진짜
한국이 맞나 할 정도로 외국인들이
굉장히 많은데 [음악] 다음 편에는
제가 이제 북촌 한옥마을 시작으로
외국인들이 좀 많이 나오는 상권들을
좀 중적으로 찍어 보도록 하겠습니다.
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.